Alex Trebek as you know his battling
stage four pancreatic cancer he says at
times he has cried in pain in his
dressing room and now alex is getting
candid about wearing a wig due to chemo
a challenge for jeopardy viewers is
right now is that Alex's real hair or is
that a full hair piece because they all
know that when you start chemo you lose
your hair this is not the real meat the
78 year old opens up about losing his
hair while sitting down with Jane Pauley
at his Los Angeles home I'm told that
there were times when the hair piece
looked better than my real hair Alex
just won a Daytime Emmy Award and says
he's hopeful by the fall he can ditch
the wig we have the summer months off so
hopefully my own hair will grow back
because I like my own hair and in
another health update Chuck job Howard
Stern is talking for the first time
about his own cancer scare the weird
thing about it was I couldn't admit it
to the audience
in 2017 he had surgery for a growth on
his kidney the author of Howard Stern
comes again also tells CBS Sunday
morning it turned out to be a harmless
cyst I'm human and it hit me like a ton
of bricks
[Music]